You are stepping into the study of a weary student, opening a text titled, O Beloved Son, which carries a stark and uncompromising teaching.
The knowledge a scholar never acts on may be the exact thing for which he is most severely judged.
Knowledge alone without righteous deeds will not benefit you on the day of judgment.
And we really need to sit with the context here because we are examining a highly specific crisis of faith and intellect.
Right.
The subject is a disciple who is absolutely not a beginner.
He has spent years accumulating study, gathering texts, memorizing vast theoretical concepts.
He's been absorbing the wisdom of his teacher for years, yet he writes to his teacher asking for something distinct.
He asks for saving knowledge.
Which is a heavy phrase, you know.
And to frame this request, he invokes a specific prayer from the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
We should look at the exact words he uses to frame that anxiety.
The prayer is, I seek Allah's refuge from knowledge that is of no benefit.
We need to pause and examine the psychology of that request.
Seeking refuge implies an active, looming threat.
It does.
I mean, we are conditioned to view education and information as inherently good or at worst completely neutral.
The student's use of this prayer reveals a deep internal anxiety.
He possesses vast amounts of information, but he suspects deep down that much of it will not help him when it actually counts.
He is asking the master who wrote this letter to his student, Gaz A.H.
Lee, to sift through everything he has ever been taught.
He wants him to hand over the single distilled piece of knowledge that will spare him.
That anxiety is the engine of the entire text.
To treat knowledge as something from which you must seek divine protection, it completely inverts how we usually think about learning.
We operate under the assumption that acquiring more information is always a net positive.
We hoard facts.
We build these massive internal libraries.
Exactly.
But the prophet's prayer shatters that assumption entirely.
It establishes A category of knowledge that is not merely useless, but actively dangerous to the soul.
The student senses this danger.
He feels the weight of his unacted upon learning.
But his proposed solution is fundamentally
flawed.
He assumes the cure for his anxiety is to acquire yet another teaching.
Like a secret summary or a final masterful distillation from his teacher.
Yeah, he wants one more concept to memorize, hoping that the right concept will finally spark the transformation.
The master's response refuses this premise completely.
It is an immediate heavy blow that dismantles the student's entire framework of seeking.
The letter opens with conventional warmth, praises, blessings, addressing the student as his dear beloved son and true friend.
That warmth only serves to heighten the impact of what immediately follows.
The master turns the entire premise of the letter back on the disciple.
He points to the outward conduct and inner states of the prophet and the traditions that carry that counsel.
He tells the student plainly, if you have received guidance from those sources, you need no further counsel from me.
And if you have not received benefit from them, then you must ask yourself
you have truly been doing all these years.
He is holding up a mirror to the student's paralysis.
The master refuses to hand over a new piece of information because he diagnoses the problem not as a lack of water, but as a flaw in the vessel.
The fountain of guidance has been pouring for years.
The water is abundant, pure, and accessible.
If you find yourself still thirsty after years of standing under that fountain, the master suggests the problem is not that you are standing under the wrong source.
The problem is that your cup is turned upside down.
The student's letter is essentially asking, which is the right water.
The master's response redirects the inquiry.
Why is the cup turned upside down?
The deficit is never on the side of the teaching.
The deficit is entirely in the posture of the student who diligently gathers the water, studies its properties, but never actually drinks it.
Keeping the cup turned upside down functions as a brilliant, deceptive protective mechanism for you.
It allows a person to stand near the water, to converse endlessly about the water.
And to be seen by others as a dedicated seeker of the water, all without ever having to undergo the painful internal transformation that comes from actually swallowing it.
The student feels safe because he is in the vicinity of truth, confusing proximity for consumption.
That distinction between proximity and consumption brings us to the diagnostic lens of the text.
The master stacks 3 severe warnings at the very head of the letter.
These are not general pieces of advice.
They are diagnostic criteria through which you must evaluate your own life.
The first warning addresses how a life is spent.
It states, a servant's preoccupation with useless matters is a sign that Allah has withdrawn his special favor from him.
That is a staggering metric to apply to your daily routine.
It goes further.
He adds, and if even a single moment of a servant's life passes in pursuit of something other than that for which Allah created him, then that is a matter of immense sorrow.
Look at the twofold nature of this verdict.
First,
there is the tragedy of wasted time.
Second and infinitely more concerning is the theological implication.
The waste is not treated as a mere accident of scheduling or a lapse in focus.
It is identified as the visible mark of an invisible withdrawal of divine favor.
But defining any preoccupation with useless matters as a sign of divine withdrawal leaves literally no room for human exhaustion, does it?
Are we demanding A relentless machine-like productivity from a fragile human soul?
where even a brief rest or an aimless hour signifies that God has abandoned us.
I will leave a moment of complete silence right here to honor the weight of that challenge.
The text is addressing the overarching trajectory of a life, not the necessary mechanics of physical recovery.
So it's not a blanket condemnation of sleeping or eating.
No, the Master is not speaking against rest.
Rest that sustains the body and mind so that the individual can return to their purpose is not a useless matter.
It is the required maintenance of the human vessel.
What this warning targets is the active, habitual pursuit of the irrelevant.
It specifically addresses the scholar or the seeker who spends their waking hours debating trivialities, chasing status, or losing themselves in pursuits that carry zero weight in the ultimate accounting.
When a life becomes patterned by these endless empty pursuits,
It indicates that the soul has been left to its own devices.
The withdrawal of divine favor is entirely invisible from the inside.
You do not feel a sudden absence.
The only way you can detect that you have been left alone is by looking objectively at what fills your hours.
If your hours are consumed by matters that evaporate upon your death, that emptiness is the primary diagnostic symptom that favor has been withdrawn.
Unacted upon knowledge creates a habit of spiritual drift.
And that drift is the evidence of the withdrawal.
Critically at those hours leads directly into the master's second warning, which imposes A rigid, inescapable timeline on you.
The warning states, an individual whose condition, even after 40 years of age, is such that the good within him does not prevail over the evil should prepare to go to hell.
It completely removes the illusion of endless tomorrows.
The 40-year clock is a structural, biological, and spiritual reality in this teaching.
The master acknowledges that giving this advice is simple, but absorbing its reality is agonizing.
Consider what actually happens at the age of 40.
The period of youth, of endless formation, of exploring limitless potential permanently closes.
The physical structure of the human being reaches its absolute peak.
and begins its slow, inevitable descent.
The warning suggests that if, by the time that physical pick is reached, the inner scales have not tipped.
If the trajectory of the individual's habits and actions is not yet net upward.
Then the time for unconcerned drift has expired.
The in reality has calcified.
Applying this 40-year clock to you forces a harsh confrontation with your own inner scale.
We operate under the comforting illusion of infinite time to correct our course.
We assume that someday, somehow, our accumulated knowledge and good intentions will spontaneously translate into virtue.
We tell ourselves we are just in a phase of preparation.
But if decades pass and you arrive at 40 and the raw objective accumulation of your physical actions still tilts toward harm, negligence, or empty performance.
The text demands that you abandon the hope of a spontaneous, effortless transformation.
The habits you have built are the person you
You are told to prepare for the inevitable outcome of the path you have solidified through decades of repetition.
That hardening of habits is most catastrophic for the specific type of listener the master is addressing.
He is not primarily targeting the layman whose appetites simply drown out the call of conscience.
He is targeting the scholar, the student of religion, the philosopher.
This is the figure who acquires wisdom, masters the texts, and gathers worldly learning.
This individual imagines that the sheer possession of this knowledge will be his means of salvation.
All while enjoying the fame, deference, and prestige it brings him in the current life.
This self-deception leads to the third and heaviest warning.
Which is at the absolute core of the scholar's identity.
It states, on the day of judgment, the most severe torment will be visited upon the scholar whom Allah did not benefit through his knowledge.
That is, one who did not act upon what he acquired.
Notice exactly who is most exposed to danger here.
It is not the ignorant.
It is not the openly rebellious.
It is the learned soul.
The scholar acquires the terminology, learns the complex arguments, and masters the sciences.
But somewhere along that journey of accumulation, the scholar makes a fatal internal substitution.
He assumes that the mastery of the theory is the salvation.
He effectively grants himself an exemption from the physical, demanding, unseen like of the body.
He believes that because he understands the theory of the work so perfectly, he is no longer required to perform it.
The deference and prestige the scholar enjoys become a psychological shield.
Because others constantly look to him for answers, he assumes he has already arrived at the destination.
He thinks it is beneath him, or simply unnecessary, to engage in the basic physical acts of obedience.
He does not realize that the very knowledge he acquired and left untouched will transform into the instrument of his own prosecution.
It is one thing to fail out of genuine ignorance.
It is an entirely different order of failure to hold the map in your hands, to explain the map beautifully to a crowd of admirers, and yet refuse to take a single physical step
the path it outlines.
The danger of this unacted upon knowledge moves from a theoretical warning into a visceral vision from beyond the grave.
To break through the student's defenses, the master steps away from the prophetic warnings and turns to a recorded dream.
Forcing you to confront the ultimate accounting.
He recounts the dream of a great master of the inner path who shaped generations of seekers, J.
Unaid,
We are speaking of one of the most revered figures in the entire tradition.
A man whose public discourses, lectures, and spiritual signs define the path for countless disciples.
After this great master's death, a certain saint sees him in a dream and asks him a simple, direct question.
Tell me is your state after death?
The reply delivered in the dream is staggering in its brevity and its dismissal of a lifetime of public achievement.
He says, all discourses and spiritual signs turned out to be of no avail.
But
cycles of prayer I had performed during the night were of benefit.
We really need to unpack the devastation of that phrase of no avail.
The phrase strips away every illusion of worldly legacy.
His teachings, his lectures, his subtle indications, his libraries of books, none of these were condemned as evil.
They were simply weightless.
When placed on the scale that determines his eternal state, they registered as zero.
The public acts of teaching, the brilliant insights that moved crowds to tears, the gathering of devoted disciples, none of it tipped the scale in his favor.
What actually weighed on the scale, the only thing that had mass in the next world,
was a small, specific number of cycles of voluntary night prayer.
The text specifies this practice as ta e jjud, the prayer performed in the final, deepest portion of the night.
This is a practice defined entirely by secrecy and physical effort.
It requires a person to leave the warmth of their bed in the dark when absolutely no one is watching and perform physical movements of devotion.
It is not a conceptual exercise.
It is bodily.
It forces the ego into submission through physical exhaustion and isolation.
The contrast
in this dream forms the spine of the entire letter.
The smallest acted upon practice outweighed an entire lifetime of taught but untouched wisdom.
The physical act of standing in the dark, bowing and prostrating actions that require no advanced degree, no eloquence, and no audience to understand carried eternal weight.
The vast oceans of theoretical knowledge delivered masterfully to thousands carried no weight at all.
This dream is the master's entire thesis rendered in a single devastating image.
that the currency of the next world is not intellect, it is action.
Knowledge alone without righteous deeds will not benefit you on the day of judgment.
To ensure this verdict cannot be debated, misunderstood, or rationalized away, the Master delivers 2 strict parables.
These are not gentle, comforting stories.
They're engineered to violently strip away any remaining illusions the disciple might hold about his own safety.
The first parable places a person in the sudden, mortal danger of a jungle.
A person is passing through a dense jungle or a harsh desert.
He is heavily armed.
He is carrying 10 sharp swords, fine bows, and various other specialized weapons.
More importantly, he is not just carrying them.
He possesses full, perfect knowledge of the art of war.
He knows exactly how to wield every weapon he carries.
their balance, their reach, and their lethality.
Then suddenly a massive, terrifying lion confronts him, ready to attack.
The master asks a rhetorical question of the student.
Can that person be saved from the lion without actually using those weapons?
The answer is obvious and undeniable.
He cannot.
The components of this parable are exact and unforgiving.
The weapons are not defective.
The man's knowledge of warfare is not flawed or incomplete.
The lion is completely real and its intent is lethal.
The crisis rests entirely on the gap between potential and action.
Knowledge standing perfectly in the mind and weapons held securely in the hand cannot substitute for the actual physical swing of the arm.
The man can recite the precise metallurgical properties of the sword.
He can explain the physics of the bow's tension.
He can lecture the lion on the vast history of human warfare, but unless his arm physically swings the weapon, he will be torn apart.
The master draws the parallel directly
scholar.
If someone knows 100,000 intricate points of jurisprudence but does not act on them, that knowledge will be of absolutely no benefit when the crisis arrives.
Jurisprudence without action cannot save you from the lion.
The lion represents the ultimate, unavoidable accounting of death and judgment.
You cannot present your library card to the lion.
You cannot hand the lion a list of your credentials or a summary of your debates.
You must swing the sword.
The knowledge only becomes a shield when it is translated into the physical motion of a deed.
The second parable shifts the scene from the sudden, violent crisis of the jungle to the slow, creeping decline of the sick room.
A sick person is suffering from a fatal illness.
He knows exactly which medicines contain his cure.
He possesses flawless knowledge of their healing properties, their ingredients, and their dosages.
Yet he leaves the medicine sitting on the table unswallowed.
Will the abstract knowledge of those medicines
cure the physical illness in his body.
No.
Knowing the chemical composition of the cure does nothing to alter the corrupted state of the blood.
The body remains sick while the mind perfectly understands the cure.
The master then delivers the final punchline to this sequence with the brevity of a poet.
Even if you purchase 2,000 pounds of wine, you will not become intoxicated until you physically drink from it.
Look at the three distinct registers of human urgency the master has just deployed to trap the student.
The lion represents mortal danger, immediate, violent, undeniable.
The sick man represents long patience, a slow, creeping reality where the end is absolutely certain but delayed over time.
The man surrounded by wine represents obvious foolishness, the sheer absurdity of acquiring a substance for a specific effect and then stubbornly refusing to ingest it.
In all three scenarios, the diagnosis remains identical.
The substance to solve the problem is perfectly present.
The intellectual knowledge of how the substance works is complete, but the physical body has not received the substance.
The arm has not swung the sword, the throat has not swallowed the medicine, the lips have not tasted the wine.
The physical self has been granted an exemption from the process, and because of that single failure, the entire process fails completely.
Knowing is not a substitute for doing.
Moving from the parables,
The master locks his argument into place using the foundational texts of the tradition.
Specifically the verses regarding the atom's weight and the absolute necessity of striving.
The word used for this intense, physical, ego-crushing striving is mujehada.
The master quotes the undeniable verse, human beings will attain only what they have striven for.
The master anticipates a scholarly objection here because he knows exactly how the learned mind operates.
He knows the student might attempt to argue that this specific verse was abrogated by other verses emphasizing grace or predestination.
The master does not even bother to engage in a debate over abrogation.
He simply grants the objection for the sake of argument and then lines up three more verses that are universally accepted, forming an unbreakable backstop.
Quotes the verse as establishing the microscopic precision of the ultimate scales.
Whoever has done an atom's weight of good shall see it, and whoever has done an atom's way of evil shall see it.
He quotes the verse requiring anyone who hopes to meet their Lord to actually perform righteous deeds.
Then he points to the recurring, unbreakable conjunction found repeatedly throughout the text.
Verily, those who believe in Allah and perform righteous deeds, these two elements are named the exact same breath.
They are prominently welded together.
The master adds another verse detailing the explicit conditions of exception from ruin.
Except for those who repented from their sins and believed and performed righteous deeds.
Repentance.
Faith, action.
It is a required sequence, and action is the inescapable final step.
To cement this required sequence, the master brings forth 2 foundational definitions of the religion to remove any lingering doubt.
First, he cites the hadith of the five pillars.
The structure of Islam is built upon 5 things.
Testifying, establishing regular prayers, paying obligatory charity, fasting, and performing pilgrimage.
Notice the verb the prophet uses.
It is built.
Four of those five pillars are taxing, demanding,
physical actions of the body.
They require time, money, hunger, and physical exhaustion.
The 5th, the testimony, is the physical action of the tongue ratifying the unseen belief of the heart.
Then comes the hadith, defining what faith itself actually is.
Faith, or E-M-A-A-N, is defined in three inseparable parts.
To testify with the kung, to affirm with the heart, and to act upon the teachings of Islam with the limbs.
So tying faith inextricably to physical bodily movement seems to reduce an internal spiritual state to a mechanical checklist.
Belief and intent are inherently internal realities.
So if we insist that faith must include the action of the limbs, aren't we turning faith into a visible performance rather than an invisible truth?
Does this mean a paralyzed person or someone physically incapable of these specific movements possesses no faith?
I will just pause and let a sentence of silence pass before I answer that.
The tradition anticipates exactly that distinction, which is why we must look at how the hadith of the five pillars defines the architecture of belief.
It's A structural argument.
The master is not addressing a lack of physical capacity.
The tradition universally accommodates the sick, the frail, and the paralyzed, judging them by their intent and whatever limits they can reach.
He is directly addressing
a scholar who has total vibrant physical capacity but chooses paralysis out of arrogance.
He is addressing the specific individual who claims their internal reality is so pure, so elevated, and so intellectually refined that it no longer requires the crude external effort of the body.
To the master, an internal reality that does not push the limbs into motion when the limbs are fully capable is not a refined reality.
It is a dead reality.
Leaving out the action of the limbs when you possess the power
to move them doesn't just result in a weakened state of faith.
By definition, it ceases to be faith at all.
If the heart truly affirms the reality of the Creator, the body has no choice but to move in servitude.
The limbs are the undeniable evidence of the heart's conviction.
This unyielding insistence on action leads to a crucial juncture in the letter.
The master has driven the point so hard that he anticipates a massive theological pitfall forming in the student's mind.
If he pushes the absolute necessity of physical deeds this relentlessly,
The student might naturally conclude that salvation is a strict mathematical transaction.
That deeds are the literal currency that buys entry into paradise.
The master pauses the entire momentum of the letter to deliver a careful, essential clarification.
He writes, should a thought arise in your heart that I am saying a servant of God will enter paradise, not by Allah's grace, but solely by his own deeds.
Know that you have not understood my meaning.
On the contrary, a servant will enter paradise because of Allah's favor, generosity, and blessings.
We are looking at a profound paradox that sits at the center of the text.
The Master spends pages proving through parables and verses that without physical deeds you are utterly doomed, you will be eaten by the lion, you will die of the illness.
Then in the very next breath, he explicitly states that your deeds do not save you.
Only grace saves you.
Unpacking this requires us to look at the exact mechanism of the relationship between human action and divine grace.
Deeds are not the payment.
You cannot purchase eternal salvation with a few decades of flawed, distracted, and often self-serving human effort.
The math simply does not work.
The value of eternal paradise infinitely outweighs the value of your limited worship.
Grace is the door through which one must pass, but that door has a hinge.
The deeds are the hinge.
The master argues that unless a servant makes himself deserving of mercy through the physical posture of worship and obedience, he will not be in a position to receive that mercy.
The soul's active posture of worship prepares the ground for the grace to land.
Without the deeds, the ground is hard and rejects the rain.
The master seals this pivotal concept with a verse.
Verily, the mercy of Allah is close to the doers of good.
The mercy is near, but it is not near to everyone indiscriminately.
It is near to a specific category of people.
It is near to those who are acting, the doers of good.
The master then repeats his own question twice to force the dense student to finally absorb it.
How then will a servant enter paradise without the mercy of Allah?
I repeat this important point.
How will a servant enter paradise without?
If the student tries to retreat to the comforting argument that we enter on account of internal faith alone, without the need for deeds, the master blocks that exit too.
He warns that relying on faith alone means facing formidable, terrifying valleys of obstacles.
The most daunting of these obstacles is carrying one's faith safely to the very end of life, through the agonies of death.
Faith is not a static possession locked safely in a vault.
It is a journey, and the journey is hazardous.
Without the protective, hardening shell of righteous deeds surrounding it, the core of faith is exposed, fragile, and easily lost or corrupted before the end arrives.
To illustrate the exact psychological posture required to receive this grace, the master tells the story of the angel and the worshipper.
Functions as the inverse of Junaid's dream.
In the dream, the tiny physical action was the only thing that counted.
In this story, the worshipper is explicitly told his lifetime of action is completely worthless.
There was a man among the children of Israel who worshipped Allah with immense unbroken devotion.
An angel was sent to test him.
The angel arrived with a message engineered to break the man's spirit and shatter his worldview.
The angel announced, Allah the Holy says that you have been tormenting your
yourself to no purpose, for your worship is not accepted by him and you will go to hell.
Put yourself in the position of that worshiper.
You have dedicated your entire life to physical exertion, to fasting, to prayer, to isolation, to obedience.
An angel, an undeniable, terrifying messenger of absolute truth stands before you and tells you that the account is closed.
The effort is entirely rejected.
Your destination is hell.
The transaction you thought you were making, trading earthly discomfort for eternal reward, is voided in an instant.
The worshipper's response is the still center of the entire chapter, the ultimate example of the posture the student must achieve.
The worshipper does not collapse into despair.
He does not try to bargain with the angel.
He does not pull out a ledger of his good deeds and demand an audit from the heavens.
He simply states his singular defining duty.
He says,
Allah the Exalted created us for His worship and servitude, and our duty is to serve Him no matter what.
He is the owner of all things and all people, including myself, and He is the all-powerful.
The worshiper survives this devastating test because he is not operating on a transactional model.
He recognizes his fundamental, inescapable nature as a servant.
A servant does not dictate terms to the owner.
A servant does not demand payment.
A servant serves because that is what a servant is.
It is his ontological reality.
The worship was not a coin he was using to buy paradise.
The worship was the inescapable reality of his existence.
Because the worshiper's service became fixed, absolute, and unconditional, divorced entirely from the calculation of reward, God did not turn his face away.
The angel returns to the heavens and reports the man's steadfast reply.
Allah answers.
Since this servant of ours does not turn his face away from our worship and servitude, we too will not turn our face away from him.
The prophet's seal upon the story is the divine declaration.
my angels, bear witness, all of you, that I have forgiven him.
The dynamic revealed here is vital for you to understand.
The action grounded purely in obedience, totally divorced from the calculation of return, drew down the very forgiveness that Tess pretended to withhold.
Action is its own ground.
When you act out of absolute servitude, recognizing you deserve nothing,
Grace meets you on that exact ground.
This profound realization brings the master to the closing turn of the section.
He moves from the harsh diagnosis to the hinge of the cure, the practice of self-accounting.
He quotes the command, take account of yourselves before you are taken to account on the day of judgment and weigh your deeds.
That is, critically examine and correct the shortcomings in your deeds before your deeds are weighed and judged, and reward or punishment is decreed.
Establishing an inner court in this world allows you to render a verdict on yourself before the terrifying, inescapable outer court in the next world does it for you.
It requires A brutal, unflinching honesty about what you actually do with your limbs versus what you merely know in your head.
To cement the exact posture you must take in this inner court, the master lines up 3.
The first witness is the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him.
He states that a person who thinks he will reach paradise without righteous striving is hopelessly self-deluded.
And a person who thinks he will reach paradise through striving alone is merely exhausting himself.
It is the perfect articulation of the paradox.
You must strive with everything you have, but you must absolutely not rely on the striving to save you.
The second witness is an early teacher of the city of Basra, A.J.
San El-Baisri.
His statement cuts straight to the bone of human arrogance.
To desire paradise without good deeds is itself a sin among the sins.
Think about the severity of that.
The very desire for salvation, if it is uncoupled from the physical effort to attain it, is categorized as a transgression.
It is an insult to the reality of the divine court to expect the reward without lifting the sword.
The third witness is another intimate of God who defines the exact psychological balance required to survive this journey.
The reality is that one should act without admiring one's own actions.
But one should never abandon the performance of good deeds, even if there is a risk of self-admiration.
You do the work.
You fiercely refuse to be impressed by your own work.
And you never let the fear of arrogance trick you into stopping the work entirely.
These 3 voices lock the overarching rule into place for the student and for you.
Striving alone does not arrive at the destination.
Not striding certainly does not arrive.
Acting without complacency, knowing without abandoning the physical act,
This is the exact narrow posture required.
The diagnosis is complete.
The student has been shown the terrifying figure of the scholar of 100,000 points who stands paralyzed in the jungle.
He has been shown the sick man holding the bottle of a cure he will not drink, the fool sitting thirsty among the barrels of wine.
He has been given the final doctrinal sentence.
Knowledge alone, without righteous deeds, will not benefit you on the day of judgment.
The final image left hanging in the air is the most urgent one.
The jungle surrounds you.
The lion is coming to the trees.
The 10 swords are heavy in your hand.
The question remains, will the arms swing?
Which known prescription sits unswallowed in your life right now, and what smallest physical deed could you begin this week to take the cure?